hey guys it is Friday again which means
I've got the five biggest stories of the
whole gaming week set to go for you so
let's see what's kicking off
[Applause]
[Music]
November Destiny 2 is coming and whether
you're excited about it or not there's
little Gamers like less than being told
the next installment is coming when the
first one only just came out not only
that the two upcoming DLC Packs aren't
even out yet Activision have confirmed
in financials call that Destiny 2 is
already in development previously the
publisher said they had a 10-year plan
for the destiny franchise which has been
described as a Lord of the Rings style
narrative we also found out that Destiny
has 9.5 million registered users which
is
madness The Sims 4 now has pools and EA
aren't even charging you for them is
this real life yep as a part of a new
patch The Sims for is now letting you
build pools the regular way diagonally
with Windows on the walls deep pools
shallow pools whatever you want there's
pools and the virtual Mansion dream is
alive again although who am I kidding
it's more like the killing off your Sims
by Drowning dream is alive
again in other news a firstperson
perspective feature was confirmed for
the next generation release of GTA 5 and
it looks just as cool as you'd hoped
Rockstar seem to have put a lot of
effort into this one they've optimized
the animations for first person and
included lots of little touches to the
inside of vehicles including accurate
speedometer and radio displays the dev
have released a trailer comparing last
gen to this new version where they've
boasted about replacing every texture in
the game increasing draw distances and
generally making the world look far
better than the last gen console
version Ubisoft have apparently decided
to make sure everybody knows that's the
PC gaming service worse than origin by
pulling their games off of steam
Assassin's Creed Unity Far Cry 4 and the
crew which were previously available for
pre-order on valve service have been
pulled from Steam worldwide if you want
them digitally you will have to go
through ubisoft's own Uplay service a
Ubisoft rep told PC games and that the
decision is for the time being but at
least for the time being it seems games
users will continue saying this is the
definition of
insanity let's finish off with the
freaking awesome news that the Legend of
Zelda Majora's musk is coming to the 3DS
in Spring of
2015 the spectacularly dark Zelda entry
was long rumored to get the Remake
treatment but now it's been officially
confirmed in a Nintendo Direct
presentation this week the presentation
showed off a trailer which gave us our
first glimpse of the 3DS version and
while pricing hasn't been confirmed
it'll likely come up at the typical $40
Mark in the US as for your question of
the day let me know what you cared about
this week and if you're more excited for
GTA's firsters perspective or the
Majora's Mask remake or both or neither
whatever this week on site check out the
first episode of in 2 minutes which
takes a look at Call of Duty the gist
asks if we have too many futuristic
Shooters and we review Call of Duty
Advan Warfare that is it for me this
week I'll be back on Monday but be sure
to have yourselves a lovely weekend
until
[Music]
then